[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show we learned
yesterday during our live stream of the
supreme court confirmation hearings of
judge katanji brown jackson that the
former secretary of state madeleine
albright has died at the age of 84.
albright was the first
female u.s secretary of state as you may
recall she was followed by well let's
see condi rice was secretary right or
was she secretary of defense now i don't
remember no she was secretary of state
yeah oh yeah uh and then of course
hillary clinton as secretary of state
are those those are the three right
female secretaries of state if i recall
correctly up until now but i'm sure many
more will will come and will follow the
place of madeleine albright and others
indeed and albright i mean listen
i found albright to be a fascinating
historical figure and historical or a
historical figure really she was both
she was such a big personality that i
would say she was both and there are a
lot of there are some people on the left
who really despised albright because
they would argue that
she was an example of her identity
being used to completely ignore her
toxic conservative neoliberalism and i
remember even one time when anna
casparian our friend from the young
turks went to the munich security
conference and interviewed madeleine
albright this was just just right before
covet i think
and the usual suspects like gren glenn
greenwald and people like that they were
saying this is part of tyt's
reinforcing the neoliberal centrist
status quo and providing cover for war
criminals and all these different things
it's like anna did a totally reasonable
interesting interview with madeleine
albright they talked about the fact that
prior to her there had not been a female
secretary of state and what the dynamics
were and how foreign dignitaries related
to that i find that there's two things
here there's her politics and yeah okay
she wasn't a progressive fine
but she was incredibly intelligent and
broke what at the time had been sort of
a glass ceiling of sorts yeah i think a
lot of progressives also didn't like her
because didn't she have that quote about
how there's a special place in hell for
women who don't support each other and
she was saying that in the context of
hillary clinton's kansas candidacy so
the idea was that if you're a woman who
doesn't support hillary then you're sort
of betraying other women that's one
interpretation but there was another
thing where i thought what she said was
reasonable which is the options are
hillary who would be the first female
president and is a woman
and
trump who is an open misogynist accused
by 46 women of sexual assaults like in
that sense her comment kind of made
perfect sense like you know i'm not like
a big identity politics guy and i
concede it could be interpreted two
different ways but it's sort of like
listen if you're a woman and you look at
these two choices and you vote for trump
that's crazy and i agree
there's also progressives who think that
she was guilty of war crimes because she
pulled out uh un personnel from rwanda
ahead of the genocide in the 90s there
which is an interesting take because
usually you would accuse someone of
being guilty of war crimes for putting
in troops or for something they did
global affairs right for getting too
involved so it sounds like maybe people
are trying to have it both ways by
claiming that she was guilty by removing
troops and of course
she sort of learned the lesson of what
happened in rwanda and also in bosnia
with uh kosovo in 1999 and the u.s got a
lot more directly involved with that
conflict so i mean that's sort of going
over her record as secretary of state
which was mixed obviously as everyone's
is uh but you know people it seems like
try to find these reasons to criticize
her when they're not necessarily um
appropriate nobody's record is perfect i
think we would all agree and
particularly anybody operating at the
level of secretary of state no no
cabinet secretary is going to have a
completely clean record
uh per from a progressive standpoint i
think there are some
secretary ships that are less overtly
controversial like secretary of
transportation is just by its nature
less likely to be accused of war crimes
than secretary of state that's just a
reality but in the modern world when
you're secretary of state for a country
like the united states i don't think any
secretary of state would ever meet the
ideal progressive image
yeah and i would certainly rank albright
ahead of folks like i don't know mike
pompeo yeah rex tillerson colin powell
she certainly bested them no question
about it and um one of the things i
really liked about albright
was
that one of her big missions one of her
big values was
complete in total opposition to
totalitarianism
and fascism
and she learned later in life she wasn't
raised jewish she learned later in life
about her family's jewish heritage and
there's a lot of very interesting things
in her background and she was a strict
opponent of uh totalitarianism and
fascism and so madeleine albright dead
at 84
certainly one of the most
interesting
secretaries of state
in the last
many decades i think without without a
doubt
speaking of uh folks and health issues
we are really starting to wonder
what's going on with justice clarence
thomas late last week we learned that
supreme court justice clarence thomas
one of the six right-wing justices on
the court had been hospitalized and we
were told
he is hospitalized for an infection and
is receiving antibiotics and of course
that signals it's not coveted
uh because
although some people take antibiotics
for covid it's not actually indicated
and antibiotics would not be given if he
had covered by
normal real doctors in general
um and that he was supposed to be
he was supposed to be released within a
day or two so we were expecting uh
clarence thomas to be out of the
hospital saturday or sunday
um yesterday which was wednesday
the court would not comment as to
whether he was still hospitalized but we
know he was not back on the court
yesterday and so there are of course
increasingly
suspicions that he may be sicker than is
being admitted although it may be as
simple as it's just about privacy and
there's just not been an update provided
we don't know pat and of course there's
the human piece of this which is this is
someone who is sick and we want them to
get better there is also the reality in
the timing of the fact that we're in the
middle of supreme court hearings and
that if for whatever reason clarence
thomas were to leave the court at this
time it wouldn't be joe biden replacing
a liberal with a liberal it would be joe
biden replacing a conservative with a
liberal and it would potentially shift
the balance of the court from six three
to five four
yeah and that political angle is why
there's so much attention on this yeah
like if this was let's say the secretary
of defense for example who was sick then
there wouldn't be a lot of attention
because even if the worst happened well
that person would just be replaced with
someone who is basically equal in terms
of how they go about the job and policy
and all that stuff but obviously if
clarence thomas was to pass away or have
to resign because of this sickness then
joe biden would be able to pick a
replacement and the balance of the court
would then ship to shift to five to four
and you know it's kind of strange how it
puts you in the position of like
thinking the worst or like getting kind
of morbid right because you don't want
to be obviously rooting for anyone's
death we never want to do that of course
but obviously there's the implication
that if he does pass away from this
sickness then you know you can make the
utilitarian argument that that could be
overall better for the country because
we'll have more favorable rulings and
we'll be able to shift the court back
into our favor a little bit more so like
you have to be thinking about this no
question and there's a new update from
just um 12 minutes ago clarence thomas's
hospital stay longer than expected as
new coveted variant surges but again
there is no belief that he has covid at
least as far as what we were told
uh last week and a bunch of people are
tweeting are we still supposed to
pretend he doesn't have covid i don't
know that they would lie i mean it's you
know he was hospitalized with flu-like
symptoms determined to be an infection
and given antibiotics
would they lie if it was covet i just
don't think so could he be getting an
alternative treatment like antibiotics
are typically not given for covid but
right he's seeking an alternative uh i
believe he's vaccinated right because i
remember hearing that everyone on the
supreme court was vaccinated yes so that
will obviously give him plenty of
protection uh but yeah it definitely
could be covered given everything that's
going on he also could have caught covet
after going into the hospital or could
have been negative on friday when that
announcement
we don't know we don't know but
this is
starting to get to where we would say we
are basically on day seven of him being
in the hospital complete we're in the
seventh day
and uh there are political questions
understandably being asked
this is um
[Music]
it's kind of a weird story but it's kind
of not because we know trump is very
childish and capricious
trump has unendorsed alabama senate
candidate mo brooks
mo brooks recently said republicans need
to get past the 2020 election which is
basically like saying trump's got to
stop talking about it was stolen even if
mo brooks believes it mo brooks may well
believe joe biden didn't really win or
not it doesn't really matter it's not
the point mo brooks accurately assessed
that it's bad strategy for republicans
to keep talking about 2020 and trump
lost it and put out a statement saying
that mo brooks has gone woke
and that he
um that it's wrong to put the election
behind them because it was rife with
fraud and irregularities and on and on
and on so um he has been unendorsed mo
brooks has and i guess he relatively
quickly updated his twitter profile and
his website and all sorts of stuff to
remove pictures of him with trump this
to me pat is just a story of how
childish trump is and we know trump
doesn't really care about other people
he doesn't care about his voters he
spent his life trying to stay away from
people like his voters in his country
clubs and whatever in queens and new
york city and all of this stuff when he
no longer had a use for his followers he
just kind of abandoned them and if he
needs them again he'll go back to them
but trump doesn't care about other
people
well yeah of course and it's funny how
benign this criticism was it wasn't like
mo bricks was saying oh
joe biden legitimately won and there
wasn't voter fraud he didn't go that far
which is true but yeah he just said we
need to move on from this and voters in
2022 and 2024 may not care about this
issue that much and so we should be a
little bit more forward thinking and
that was enough for trump to drop him
yeah um i also love how
trump called him woke because that's
sort of like a catch-all term like he
has nothing to do with wokeness or
identity politics or anything like that
this is a completely separate issue but
for whatever reason trump and other
republicans whenever they disagree with
someone they can just say oh they've
gone woke or they're a rhino is another
one a republican in name only
yeah but i mean the woke thing i think
is a little bit more funny because that
actually has a separate meaning right
so there's that and then also this may
have to do with trump's endorsement
record because mo brooks was polling at
a distant third place and apparently
trump cares
deeply about who wins and who loses
after he endorses them and maybe he
figures okay well if mo brooks is
destined to lose this thing then i
should back out while i still can
uh maybe there's that maybe there's that
factor at play but i don't know if trump
actually cares about the endorsement
record itself because whether it's good
or bad he'll just lie about it yeah
he'll just say it's a great record yeah
no matter what that's so funny um mo
brooks has uh said before
that after the election trump came to
him and made some impossible requests
including asking mo brooks to rescind
the 2020 election
to remove joe biden from the white house
and to put trump back in and hold a
special election and it's like well
obviously mo brooks can't do that
well yeah that's a big ask especially
for just one member of congress right
when you don't even have the majority
right it's not even like republicans
were in charge of the house of
representatives at that time it's not
like mo brooks could do that so yeah
that's quite the ask from donald trump
there and i tend to believe that
mo brooks is right in his account that
he actually did that i'm curious trump
has two rallies coming up he has a rally
this saturday in uh wait hold on
march 26 2022 trump rally this saturday
it's in
florida i guess
and then april 2nd
he has a rally in
detroit so
um i i'm curious to see to what degree
trump attacks republicans who are
increasingly they're not really even
against trump they're just saying
it's not great strategy to keep
insisting the 2020 election was stolen
when we're trying to win 2022 which
they're right about i'm curious to see
how much trump's rallies now consist of
attacking republicans as much as they
consist of attacking democrats
that's interesting because don't you
think maybe trump would want to make it
seem as though the republican party is
united behind him yeah focuses in on how
all these different republican figures
disagree with him now that may also be
bad politics but then again if he
doesn't care about the 2020 election
point that that's doing harm to him in
the movement then maybe he won't care
about this other thing either yeah i
think it's so you it's
you're making an interesting argument
which is logical which is hey you know
if you keep talking about the
republicans that are bad because they're
not saying oh yeah yeah you won sir you
won
um it would only serve to show that
there is a rift in the party and it
seems like the republican party would
benefit from at least appearing to be
united but trump doesn't think in those
terms trump thinks about what's good for
me right now and what he thinks is good
for him is for everybody to still see
him as the guy who should be in the oval
office even though there's no evidence
for that
yeah and i love to see it i love to see
the poor planning oh yeah the idea that
it's just all about him because i don't
think it's going to work it certainly
didn't work in those runoff elections in
georgia
shortly after the 2020 election so if
he's able to keep this up and if he
sabotages the republican party and their
chances of winning this year and in 2024
i'm all for it no question about it so
we're going to be watching those rallies
closely we're going to be watching mo
brooks closely we're really going to be
watching all of it closely and we will
be back tomorrow with a new show and
it's not just the new show it's also the
new bonus show it's both